OK.
It was not just rallies that Donald Trump
did this weekend.
He was also interviewed by Fox News's Mark
Levin.
Now, if you don't know who Mark Levin is,
he's almost like a protege of Sean Hannity.
If you can imagine as propagandistic and perverse
and depraved as Sean Hannity is, Mark Levin
is a guy that Hannity for years referred to
as the great one.
The interview was arguably as disconnected
from reality as any interview Donald Trump
has previously done after Donald Trump went
on a completely absurd rant about water.
Mark Levin tells him, You know what I like
about you.
You're not an ideologue.
Irony is dead.
It's dead.
Take a look.
You would have so much water in California,
you'd be able all those fields that are open.
I mean, I've never said that you're driving
down the highway and everything's like really
terrible looking.
And then you have this gorgeous patch of green.
That's the only area they have the water they
allowed like this tiny amount of water.
That whole thing could be farmland that they
send the water out into the Pacific Ocean.
You know, it's a long story, but there are
many, many stories like that.
The stupidity of it all.
So I listen to you in these different areas.
You're not an ideologue.
It's common sense.
Can you imagine seeing Donald Trump attack
people on the left who aren't even in charge
for everything from not raking forests to
not giving Trump enough water pressure to
flushes toilets?
Why Trump needs to flush 10 to 15 times, I
don't know.
And then saying, you know, what I like about
you is you're not ideological.
I have no idea how this next comment makes
sense.
Donald Trump seemingly talking about Chicago
and then jumps right into Afghanistan.
It's almost like the the it is a verbal inkblot,
I think is the right term.
Look at Chicago, where 58 people were shot
at.
This is a like where there was a high.
This is was shot that shot.
And they now the reports of 58 people were
shot this weekend in Chicago, 10 died.
Okay, let's get on to the weather.
How's the weather?
Dave always used to it.
Fifty eight people.
So we're pulling out of Afghanistan.
As you know, we're very close to getting out.
Does anybody see the connection?
Media coverage of 58 people shot in Chicago
is related to pulling out of Afghanistan.
Is this adult ADHD?
Is it cognitive decline?
Is it ignorance?
Is it panic?
And then Trump continuing his brutal assault
on water, on and on and on.
Now going on about a massive valve.
And Mark Levin just sits there nodding like
this makes sense.
Trump also talking about a very small fish.
And yet they have they have no water and they're
going to ration for everybody.
And all they have to do is let the water come
down, you know, to do with the water.
They sent it out into the Pacific Ocean.
They had this massive go up north.
And as the water comes pouring down from the
snow and they're all beautiful, nice, clean
water, they send it out because there's a
tiny little fish that they're trying to say
that's doing very poorly, by the way.
And mean it's a scout, tiny little fish doing
very poorly, doing much worse.
Now, without the water, I mean, I don't know,
you know, you'd think they'd do better with
the water, but they have this massive valve
and they turn this massive takes a whole day
into China and all that water comes and it
comes pouring and you know where it goes into
the Pacific.
Kevin McCarthy, she's vicious.
You think you can work on the water?
We can't get any water from the farm.
The rantings of a mad band truly then Trump
again raising the topic of explosive trees.
So it's just like I just live, as, you know,
California.
I met with a governor and he and honestly,
he's been very nice with words, and that's
good.
Do you think that after the interview is over,
Mark Levin says, what the hell happened?
What what on earth was Donald Trump talking
about?
Because Mark Levin is a horrible idealogue,
but he's not an idiot in the way that Donald
Trump is.
This does Mark Levin get it?
Do you think at one point the topic of Trump's
former national security adviser, John Bolton,
came up and Trump said if it were up to Bolton,
we'd be in World War Five right now?
Then there's John Bolton was a very stupid
person.
If I listened to Jumbo, we'd be in World War
Five right now.
I guess in this imaginary nightmare, Trump
would be responsible for World Wars three
and four.
But Bolton would have gotten us into World
War Five.
And then Mark Levin just nodding, nodding,
nodding, as if this makes sense.
And then speaking of people, Trump used to
work with, Trump again referenced people being
fired like dogs.
I disagree with matters very much.
He was fired by President Obama, who was fired
like a dog.
He was fired.
Does Donald Trump know what dogs are?
We know Trump doesn't relate to his children
normally.
My guess is Trump wouldn't relate to dogs
normally either.
What is fired like a dog even mean.
And then last one, Trump.
The victim here is poor Trump whining to Mark
Levin, like Mark Levin is his mommy about
how everybody treats him so unfairly.
The Washington Post is is a disaster.
You can't get a good story.
It's it's disgusting.
And then you go to ABC.
NBC probably is the worst of all.
Comcast.
I called Comcast, not Comcast.
It's a con job because they always try and
protect their name, like how legitimate they
are.
NBC is horrible.
CBS is a disaster.
And then you go into the real beauties that
Emma's DNC, as we call it.
And, of course, CNN.
But at least CNN, you know where they're coming
from.
You know, they're stone cold, dishonest, at
least you know that.
So it's a it's a sad thing.
I mean, it's a very sad thing.
Fortunately, local press is extremely good.
I get.
Great local, whenever he says free speech,
I do one or two local reporters.
These are the greatest stories.
It's like, unbelievable.
They cover it so good.
Actually, they're they're almost more enthusiastic
than I am.
And so we have that.
We have some honest media.
Fox is is good, but Fox is not what it was.
I think I'll be very honest with you.
They'd become politically correct.
You know, they think it's wonderful.
They have more Democrats on than they have
practically than they have Republicans.
I'm complaining about it all the time.
You know, with all of that being said, we're
doing much better than we did four years ago.
Tough being a billionaire president of the
United States.
Right.
You're just it's just so everybody treats
you so poorly.
Really a tough situation for Donald Trump.
These interviews are of real bona fide sociological
value, propaganda value.
It's not journalism, but hugely relevant for
propaganda studies.